小田警備を育ててから
19日
約初日間だったんですけど
おば警備は
無事でーって無事ですよ無事ですよバリバリ縁でも元気でって届いて元気でございます
こんにちははじめたそうです次でをば警備を買っせから19日が経ちました
役立つ日間ですね本には扱うまでにもちゃんとした大人になりますって書いてあったの
でもってあの結構ヤバイんで結構皆さん
元気に育ってると思いますってめっちゃ元気だなぁほんとすごいよあのマンつちまつ
まつ見ててすげーでかくなったなって思いますよ
静岡にいるときは絶対動画撮ってるんでちょっとで途切れ途切れにはなると思うんです
けどもば警備の成長の記録
見てみましょうどうぞはい2日目で1日目はいうフェス名古屋でいませんでした
やっと生まれたっぽいですね皆さん三重
ますかほらほらほら見えますかこれ結構居るなぁ結構います結構います
んあんまりまだ可愛くはないな i 中でこれからこの子たちを育てていきたいと
おもいます
はい多分3日目です
どうでしょうかたぶん年海事1立っただけで結構大きくなってる気もせないこともせ
ませんがもういなぁ
そこそこ居るな4日目ですは瀬戸さんとは
ちゃんと生きてはすぐ中の動きがう
脱ぐ気がこと早くなってるのすげーなーだいぶ動きが早くなったね今日も s 開け
ますはい5日目みーに吹い突っつく8ですねだいぶ大きくだったねわからないけど
かなりで最初と比べると確実に成長しておりますちょっとみんな元気です今日はこの
あとちょっと東京に行ってくるのでしばらくお別れたね
ではでは6日ぐらいでござい
今見えますかねえこの軍のすげー元気だがこのことか
みんなちゃんと元気に生きていますかなり大きくなってきましたね
活発で8日8日間でこれだけ大きくなりました
どんな形かっていうか大体わかるようになってきたと思います
水槽が傷ついているこの子達は何を考えているのかな
暇だろうなこんな水槽で10日目でございます10日目です
かなり実体化してきたね
[音楽]
もう形が分かる
どんな形か分かるでめっちゃ大きくなったら例えばお化けビっぽい感じになってきたと
思われます
すげー
かわいいな遠くから名湯上がると思うんですけど数が全然減ってないです
無事みんな元気に生きております
すげー
ファイト夕食で13日名です肉眼でも見れるしね
まだまだ成長するらしいんでねちょっと見ていきましょう大抵技で重要日目です
なんか皆さん大きくなって活発度が減りましたね
なんか堂々と泳ぐようになりました前からず数が多いですね
あ飲めば元気だなだいぶ大きくなってきたやばいのがいる一人
どうしたんだあんた何なんねデュース増同スター
チンパンになるぐらいしっぽが長いですね15日目でございます
でかいもうめちゃくちゃでかくなっちゃった水晶にでも全然どこにいるか分かるくらい
の大きさでかなり見た目がではっきりしてきたと思います
あんな小さい小粒だったのが今こんな大きく立つってちょっと少なくなった気がする
なぁ
so ちゃんと
あげてるし部屋の温度もそんな寒くしてないので問題ないと思うんですけど少しだよ
そうでも音は意外といたけどちょっと減った気がします
はい16日目でもう体がちょっとある
すぎ銀器そして
体が開きだしてるねなんかね数がすごい減ったんですけど78匹ぐらいになってしまい
ました
みんな元気にゆっくり泳いでます
つり革いう普通すごくないん
あのちっちゃな包まれですや米デー系
[音楽]
めっちゃくそでかいですはいた八木でいかなかったでしょうか
もうほんとね目に見えないくらい小さいタバコからもう目で見えるぐらい可愛いエビ
ちゃんに成長してくれました
癒されました本当はいえされたなんか見れたびたびさんがすごい動き早かったんですが
最初
でもなんか日が経っていくことにねちょっとのんびり何になってきて体がずっしりして
結構ちゃんと
ひらひらしてをよくようになってねいやほんとよかったですこれ本当に夏休み育て
ちゃったんですよ本当は
夏休みから秋にかけて言ってたんで僕がやっている期間がちょっとずれて
てちょっとしたらなんか全滅とかするのかなって不安だったんですけどもちゃんとね
元気に育ってくれるで僕はそういう嬉しいですまでも最初めちゃくちゃうじゃうじゃい
たんですけどもやっぱりなんか和也とか減っちゃってって何だろうないと環境とかマン
とかな寿命もあるのかな
竜日間くらいで成長しきるって書いてあったんでそろそろひょっとしたら歳なのかも
しれません
音の後警備まで成長させ
データなど良かったですねマジでやっちゃいますからねハッと見比べなんだよねクラゲ
もう普通に女でも見えるくらいなっちゃうんでサイズ的にはよく大きくなったらこんな
に愛的でを分ける差が出てきたんですけども
よかったですよされました一人で話しかけてた自分がアホみたいですでもそれくらい
愛着を持って育てられたんですごい楽しかったでございますなんかねうまくいけばた
魔法のみたいな話
ボスてたんでこの子たちが猫の咳歳をとって強くきちゃって死んじゃってもね
ひょっとしたら卵があるかもしれないんでまぁ何かあったらサブちゃんとかに出して
みようかなと思っていますまとりあえず今大人になって楽しい人生を送ってくれれば
いいなと思ってる
僕の中学校の先生が言ってたんですけどもなんで皆さん
生きてると思いますか人生なんてもんはね思い出づくりですよ
死んだら多分うの世界なんて何もないんで生きてる間にどれだけ思い出を作って楽しい
人生家屋根たかったので自分が楽しいと思うかどうかっていうね
思い出をつくることが大切なんだって中学校の先生が言ってました皆さんも
僕もお化けいるも皆さんもいつかはどうせ死ぬんで生きている間になるべくたくさん死
幸せな思い出を作ってください人生は覚えて作りですね
これ何言ってんだ何言ってんだ俺いやなんかね生き物を見てたらそういうこと思ったん
だよな
これの前世も楽しみやじゃん
[音楽]